à migennes
[Musique]
dans l'est du congo les villages minuit
sont tous très isolés souvent aux
sommets de montagnes majestueuses les
paysages à couper le souffle mais
difficile d'accès
[Musique]
après douze heures de route impossible
des pistes de roches et de boue qui
fraudent des ravins vertigineux
on découvre tout en haut
nommé le village de 22 mai l'habitat la
plupart attirés ici par l'argent des
minerais match à marseille comme nouveau
quoi joue la vie est un peu difficile
les chansons très loin si on survit
c'est parce qu'il ya les maisons mal à
passer chez un pathologie à cushing
clichés montrent l autonomie tichri rcan
à est venu vivre ici il y a deux ans
avec sa femme et leurs deux enfants elle
a 6 ans le garçon est mis 4 ans ce jour
là leur mère travaille dans son champ de
pommes de terre très loin du village
la fillette devra s'occuper de son petit
frère toute la journée pendant que son
père part travailler dans une carrière
de coltan à trois kilomètres de marche
encore plus haut dans les montagnes
[Musique]
les costumes
les causes je suis creuseurs de coltan
ce travail je peux dire qu'il est bon
parce qu'il me permet de faire vivre mes
deux enfants et de les envoyer à l'école
ménagère pourquoi sa machine 70 à 80% du
coltan de la planète vient de la
république démocratique du congo le
minerai qui nous donne les outils de la
haute technologie est encore exploité
hop etc et à l'appel comme au moyen âge
il ya un goût ça ça mais kossoko team
bakou chocs acoustiques et quoi il me
tient le plus dur c'est tu creuses et
d'arriver au niveau du sable et du
coltan
c'est dur parce que c'est très profond
et qu'on n'a pas accès à l'eau maya raic
les zones creuses d'abord dans la paroi
rocheuse en dessous ils peuvent trouver
ces cailloux de coltan qu'elle casse à
la masse ils creusent aussi des trous
dans la terre où on cherche de la
poussière de coltan mail et au sable
mais poussé maintenait tout pas qu'on
doit à tamiser le sable pour séparer de
minerais du sable et on a misé le
deuxième fois avec de l'eau pour avoir
juste le colt raté les côtes
[Musique]
ce jour là dans la carrière où travaille
ou diana il n'ya que des hommes et ce
n'est pas un hasard
les femmes et les enfants sont encore
nombreux dans les carrés miniers au
congo mais ils disparaissent quand tu
arrives des journalistes des inspecteurs
ou des militants des droits de la
personne
après ça nous allons passer dans l'étape
des parties revendiquent avait remis
nerfs pour visiter deux femmes et des
enfants qui travaillent là bas pour
trouver leur vie pour trouver leur pain
quotidien
cet employé d'une minière locale a
accepté de tourner ces images nous
protégeons son identité pour lui éviter
des représailles
moment
par exemple des carrés miniers et voilà
les enfants ou les enfants qui sont très
recherchés minery qui ont échappé au
creusot
on lui doit un peu près défense
tous ont un peu le travail
amour marguerite pour l'enfant nie
nullement carrés miniers ou colin team
adapta minorer la mine eric dane romont
la team colle pas
[Musique]
chance qui à 20 ans vient à la carrière
avec sa mère depuis qu'il est tout petit
que ses frères et soeurs ont travaillé à
la mine certains sont même morts ici
[Musique]
aruba ya un autre village minier ces
femmes dénoncent les méthodes fortes de
la société minière lissoni joue le plus
grand producteur de coltan du congo
détient presque tous les permis
d'exploitation dans la région ces hommes
armés font peur en octobre dernier lors
d'un conflit
une quinzaine de coureurs ont été tués
[Musique]
est ce qu'il ya des mamans ici qui ont
des enfants qui travaillent dans les
mines ou les grands-mères parmi ces
femmes avouent que leur enfant au
travail et dans les mines quand il était
trop jeune mais je jure que leurs petits
enfants n'y vont pas elles font de la
sensibilisation pour sortir des
carrières les enfants et les femmes
enceintes
angélique dit qu'elle a cessé de
travailler à la mine pendant sa 10e
grossesse ou à garder nicolas bbc zeldam
[Musique]
quartetto annaba qui me lie l'inde
atomique âge où djoko est niet n'a pas
atteint cas propose presque toutes ces
femmes ont été témoins d'accidents
mortels
on a des accords chez mon côté on a
gardé nos maux
chez les marines h au créneau
la chine qui charge aux valeurs de la
terre
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vraiment mal j'ai très mal quand je
vois une femme qui pleure parce que son
enfant vient d'être un cv ni christine
me sèye 10 y scolarise des enfants
pauvres et défend leurs droits
quand elle a visité une mine de coltan
elle a craqué pour ces petits qui font
un travail beaucoup trop dangereux il ya
la radioactivité parce que c'est toxique
la tuberculose est il ya halal problème
ils ont la maladie des os mais la malade
maladies pulmonaires autre chose qui à
nadal mines cette petite fille et
sociales sont violés d'où le lancement
de la campagne zéro en fond dans la mine
en mars christine a participé au
lancement d'une campagne de
sensibilisation
on a noté qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'enfants depuis ces derniers temps
chose qu'ils se battront dénonce la
présence d'enfants dans ses mines
important il les tolère l'entreprise a
refusé qu'on fume dans ces carrières et
a décliné une demande d'entrevue
je ne comprends pas pourquoi les enfants
continuent à écrire dans les puits même
d'aller la verrez au moment où la police
des mines et la politique
cet inspecteur voit encore beaucoup
d'enfants dans les mines mais il avoue
son impuissance face aux exploitants
miniers qui ignore les sanctions et le
gouvernement laisse faire
qui est capable de dire à mongo souquet
pourquoi toi retirer et andré des fait
travailler des enfants c'était nous
c'était mon tour douter comment mettre à
la porte et c'est lui qui a qui est pris
pour que thouars séduit et 10 ans il a
au besoin il a une âme
[Musique]
alors que l'équipe à l'école du village
le nombre d'élèves diminue au fur et à
mesure que l'année avance en mars près
de 300 jeunes manquaient à l'appel parce
que beaucoup d'enfants a aussi vos dates
de carrière chez eux qu'on va trouver
l'argent qu'il ya encore beaucoup
d'enfants qui travaillent à minuit
oui nous est calme les autres voix
qu'est il y a les enfants qui vola de
carrière du trophée de la région wen
afaccc procurer un téléphone huile et à
l'époque la salue tous aussi de bandes
de nouveaux records en classe
le premier réflexe des jeunes et denis
puis certains osent dire la vérité
le directeur se dit incapable de retenir
les enfants à l'école qui manque d'
absolument tout vous pouvez trouver même
cinq élèves c'est même pas cinq élèves
exxon depuis cette classe quand il pleut
des enfants doivent et sans casser ou
milliers pour que les prix s'est passé
des classes sont même effondrée parce
qu'on vient creuser le coltan jusque
sous l'école la loi y avait de fait de
classe qui était inscrite la dette alors
à cause du boulot main toute la partie a
été importée parce que les problèmes que
les gènes oppose ils ont raison ils
disent on quitte des mines on vole on ne
va pas à l'école
l'état est passé on a pas du travail
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors soit on va
d'alarmé soit en dévier bandits ou en
retrait d'amis c'est pour ouvrir
l'horizon des jeunes que la militante
veut rénover une école de rubaya et
construire un centre des métiers
mais quoi
ok voix
[Musique]
la messe du samedi et du dimanche
souvent les seuls moments de repos pour
six villageois
[Musique]
on
après la pause prière rod janois
retourne à la mine
il y va presque tous les jours
[Musique]
les creuseurs s'arrête pour manger le
seul repas de la journée
tu as aimé comme beaucoup je sais que le
coltan contribuer à fabriquer beaucoup
de choses qui ont la valeur téléphone et
beaucoup d'autres choses dispendieuse si
c'est le cas pourquoi nous ici on gagne
très peu d'argent
pourquoi ça
[Musique]
le mois dernier
rhodia a touché seulement 80 dollars il
dépense très peu d'argent pour se
nourrir lui-même ce qu'il gagne avec le
coltan il le garde pour payer le loyer
et envoyer ses enfants à l'école
jamais je n'accepterai que mes enfants
deviennent creuseurs je souhaiterais que
mes enfants fassent autre chose un autre
métier parce que la vie de creuseurs
c'est une vie trop difficile
[Musique]